حسنًا ، هنا في جناح بحركرين ،
هناك ابتسامة تفاؤل
تملأ الأجواء بتقوية
الاقتصادات في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ، وليس فقط
عائدات النفط هي التي تلفت نظر
الخبراء وفقًا لتقرير شركة PWC
، فقد بلغ النمو غير النفطي 9٪ في بعض
الذهب.  العام الماضي
والسؤال هو هل ستستمر في عام
2023 بالتأكيد أحد الأشياء التي
سأنتظرها هذا العام هو
انتعاش الاقتصاد غير النفطي.
أظهر النمو الإيجابي القوي أن دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي هي
أكثر من مجرد نفط  الاقتصاد مجال آخر
أعتقد أننا سنبدأ في
رؤية تسارع في الاستثمار
وترتبط الجهود
بانتقال الطاقة مع الشرطي 28 الذي يحدث
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة في التزامات مختلفة من
المملكة العربية السعودية والعديد من الحكومات الأخرى التي
أعتقد حقًا أن عام 2023 قد
يكون  العام المحوري الذي نرى فيه
الاستثمار في التكنولوجيا الخضراء
والطاقة الخضراء ، السؤال هو من أين
يأتي هذا الاستثمار وفقًا
لتقرير الاستثمار العالمي للعام الماضي الصادر عن مؤتمر الأمم
المتحدة  في مجال التجارة والتطورات
في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ، احتلت الإمارات العربية
المتحدة المرتبة العشرين الأولى
من حيث تدفقات الاستثمار الأجنبي المباشر ،
ويقول أحد المحللين إن المنطقة قد تتطلع إلى
التغيير لدرجة
أننا نسمع الكثير عن
التحولات والتحولات في
الشرق الأوسط ، وتحول الطاقة العالمي
نوع من التحول الاقتصادي هو
التحول الكبير الذي
سيحاول المسؤولون الحكوميون في المنطقة تحقيقه
هو أن الدولة
والحكومة ليست
الملاذ الأول والأخير لجميع
مبادرات التنمية ولكن بالأحرى حيث هناك  هو
تدفق صحي
للاستثمار الأجنبي المباشر للمساعدة في دعم هذه
الخطط الاقتصادية ،
ولكن يمكن أن تعني التوقعات الحالية لعام 2023
مزيدًا من الاستثمار لا سيما عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالطاقة الخضراء في pwc ،
يقول الاقتصاديون ربما عندما يكون هناك الكثير من Duke
and Gloom حول الاقتصاد العالمي من
تباطؤ النمو  في الواقع ، فإن دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي تبلي
بلاءً حسناً ، وعندما تعمل دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي بشكل
جيد فإنها تجذب الناس  وهو
يجلب استثمارًا ويؤثر على
حياة الجميع لأنه اقتصاد نفطي
ولكن من المهم أيضًا أن
يصبح مهمًا لأن الاقتصاد غير النفطي
يجب أن يتحرك فيه الشرق الأوسط في
تحول الطاقة ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
في منتصف الكل.  من ذلك
شكرا لك